[Music]
as promised i came back with another
video explaining how to shoot the film
profiles in terms of exposure color
temperature and color filter also how to
install the creative film lots to get
the same kind of look so i also made
some updates to film profiles to give
you even more pleasing colors and just
finished the enter in a high fidelity
profile
which a couple weeks ago i published a
tweaked version
of it but now i'm gonna publish the high
fidelity one which is about ninety-five
percent the same with the fuji that's in
a simulation so now it will be much
easier to color match these two camera
brands or just get better color out of
the sony camera
also working on a new classic chrome
koda chrome 64 from fujifilm
and we'll post a video about that in the
following weeks so let's get started
this video is shot on fuji 400 and the
first profile that has been modified is
actually vector 100. the only
modification brought to this profile is
a decrease in the black point which was
lowered to -15 to actually just increase
the contrast next on the list is the
fuji 400 so i change the black level to
plus 3
knee to 80 percent plus 1 and the
biggest modification is the reduction of
saturation to plus 5 which actually is
not even a modification because in the
original video there was a typo which
said it was at plus 15 but actually it
was always only at plus five so i'm
sorry for that the next profile is
portrait 800 so initially the porsche
800 was made to give you a candy look
but
nowadays i'm using this profile for
commercial work so i was looking for
something a little bit more natural
neutral you know
so the first modification
is i've changed the black gamma to
narrow plus seven
i brought down the saturation just a
little bit to plus 20.
uh color phase you can set it to either
zero or minus two and for the color
depth is going to be red plus three
green plus five
blue plus four
cyan minus four
uh magenta minus three and yellow minus
three
so the last profile that i've modified
is the kodak gold one set the black
level from 15 to -10 because i feel like
it's just maybe a little bit too
contrasty
uh the black gamma set it to wide and
minus seven
and also i've changed the color mode
from s gamma 3 to s gamma simple because
i noticed how
as gamma 3 actually shifts some some
parts of the l spectrum towards magenta
and that sometimes can give some weird
hues in the skin tones mostly when you
overexpose
so
just using as gamut will
eliminate that problem because it has
overall more even
yellow tones and that's exactly what i
want for koda gold
okay so now that we're done with the
modifications
let's see how we can shoot these
profiles to
get similar results so initially i made
these profiles for myself
but after i saw how well they came out i
just really wanted to share them with
everybody else so with that in mind
my style is just a little bit more moody
darker you know
with a typical color scheme so you know
might some people might say like uh all
my shots are underexposed or my skin
tones are not accurate and yeah you're
right they're not accurate because it's
not supposed to be you know if i would
be shooting commercial work yeah i would
be shooting differently but right now
i'm trying to achieve something more
artistically like a film look so as a
general guide i usually
besides portrait 800 which i overexpose
by one or two stops
with the rest of the profiles i usually
tend to underexpose
by half a stop one stop sometimes if i
want something more drastic or if i'm
doing street photography and i'm working
with silhouettes and a lot of contrasty
you know dark scenes then i'm i might
even uh other expose three stops four
stops you know five stops depending what
how harsh i want light the lighting to
be
so um
as for color temperature i usually just
stay away from the correct color
temperature so for example if you shoot
daytime you usually want to go for 5500
but if you want something more artistic
like if you're shooting film profiles
you might want to go 1000 2000 under or
above the normal temperature
for the color filter this is
this is very subjective and depending
what colors you have in the scene and
one what you want to emphasize also on
the profile
but
most of the times i think the safest
suggestion would be just to go cyan
green so probably something like
c3
g1.5 in the color filter that will
probably give you the best results in
any situation
but i will still give you uh general
guides for each profile
so you can find it easier to start
working with these
proof but i will still give you general
guides or suggestions for each profile
individually so you find it easier to
start working with them the first
profile is vector 100 usually i go for a
cyanish green look so
somewhere around
c2 g2 something like that would be fine
with me
night time i usually shoot 3 900 or 4
200.
with a super yellow filter giving it a
worm look but it can also go super warm
uh daytime or night time so
you can go let's say 2 000 kelvin above
normal and then emphasize maybe a little
bit more with some yellow filter or red
filter so maybe go something like let's
say i don't know
uh
a3 a4
and
or it can go a3 and
g4 to give more of a yellow look
uh the next profile is the noble light
with this profile i usually go a little
bit colder so maybe 500
500 1000 kelvin below and then i just
emphasize more by going into the color
filter
and uh shifting everything towards
magenta magenta or red you know it can
go both ways
uh again these are only suggestions you
can just experiment anyway in any
direction that you want but these are my
personal
most used uh settings so you can use
them as a base start
next profile is fuji 400
this actually works well in both colder
and warmer tones so go for cyan green
look or sometimes just lift up the
kelvin by 500 or 1000 and that should
work fine but this is a super versatile
profile so you can underexpose it over
expose it yeah and you can use uh you
know the temperature in both ways colder
tones or warm and tones so just play
play around with it okay the next
profile uh which is picture profile 4 is
actually set to classic chrome
this profile is still under development
but from what i've been experimenting it
works really well with warmer tones so
usually
at the moment i will shoot correct
temperature or above with 500 to 1000
kelvin and then just emphasize more on
the magenta tones on on the pink tones
by shifting the color filter
uh towards magenta probably something
like m2 or something like that next
profile is eve pro plus
it's a versatile profile but usually i
shoot colder with this profile
so maybe try going 2 000 kelvin below
normal with a green tint so
just drag the color filter towards green
maybe g2 or something like that
that's my personal preference but you
know it's a pretty versatile profile
again like most of them so just go
experiment with it and you know try
different colors ectel 100 i usually uh
shoot it
either really really cold and with a
green tint just like uh if pro plus
where i go super hot super warm because
it has this saturated like super soft
contrast and i really like to usually
daytime i like to go maybe a little bit
warmer than usual 1000 to 2000 kelvin
above normal and from there i just you
know depending what kind of colors i
have in in the scene i just emphasize
more on the yellow tones or on the
red magenta tones
as you noticed until now i most of the
times i just go somewhere around cyan
green
or
red magenta because those are my
favorites so next profile is portrait
800 again this is a versatile profile
but i usually don't shoot it at
different
temperature than the correct one so
let's say if it's daytime i i shoot at
5500
because i like to have the full spectrum
of color i usually use it to further
color grade but you can also use it
with more creative stuff just like i did
in my last video of cine still 800 t
look so just maybe go below 2500 kelvin
to get a super
uh blue tint and then just color grade
from there depending what you want but
this is a really beautiful profile
because it can give you really nice skin
tones and natural colors and super soft
gradations you know and with this
variation of the profile you will get
less
chromatic uh noise
which is just wonderful so just try it
out
i think it's it's just wonderful for
anybody even if you shoot 10 bit just
use it because
uh it will just save you so much time
and card grading the next profile is
kodak gold definitely go hot with this
profile this is the only way that i do
uh this is the only way that i i use it
i just go hot
1000 2000 maybe 3 000 kelvin above
normal you can also emphasize by going
towards red in the color filter uh
towards yellow or magenta
and uh yeah that's pretty much it it
gives you really good results
so on picture profile nine it's uh it's
sony eterna simulation the high fidelity
one so not the last from my last video
this is the high fidelity one which is
90 to 95 percent uh
accurate to the fuji gum simulation i
haven't tested too much with this
profile but you can try any of the above
and let us know in the comments if you
find any other interesting settings
the last profile is blue velvet
definitely i'm going nostalgic with this
one
so gonna take it to magenta blue to
accentuate the natural earthy tones but
with the kelvin i will usually raise it
just a little bit maybe 200 maybe 500
maximum 1000 kelvin above normal and
then just kind of like drag the color
filter down towards blue until i feel
it's right
yeah you can also go into the extremes
if you want a more artistic look
definitely nothing wrong with that uh
just try to feel the mood and what
colors the scene is looking for or
asking for
so guys these are only suggestions not
golden rules not at all golden rules
and even rules are made to be broken
because otherwise nothing great will be
created so you know i'm trying i'm just
trying to offer you a base start uh for
these film profiles so you can start
shooting you know to have fun with them
because many people ask me how do i
shoot this how do you expose how to use
the temperature whatever to get the same
kind of color so this is it you know
like uh this is how i usually do it but
don't limit yourself inside rules just
try to experiment you know with color
and with exposing and just try to feel
your gut you know that's what it's about
i'm never thinking like
i'm not following it rules usually i'm
not thinking like oh i usually do this
or i usually do that no i'm just looking
at the scene and i'm kind of trying to
feel my gut like what colors i should
emphasize how should i expose you know
because sometimes i overexpose sometimes
i underexpose
so you don't need to follow these rules
like they are made of gold
yeah
currently i'm working on a classic
chrome or koda chrome 64 profile and
we'll be releasing that in the following
weeks together with the high fidelity
fujifilm editor in the profile so
subscribe to see that video coming up
let me also let me know in the comments
if if you want any film profiles or what
film stock you would like me to
simulate i will check into that if it's
possible i'll make it so let's see
and it's just wonderful how sony has
given us so much control over the final
image inside of the camera and pretty
much no other brand is doing this you
know like fuji's doing something but
they won't let you actually control the
luma values of the colors and you know
you don't have as many color modes as
sony also you know the overall picture
profile has a little bit more control
than uh fuji also fuji has some controls
that you know
sony doesn't have but what i'm trying to
say like most camera brands don't offer
this
and uh you know it's great but i still
feel like there is some improvement that
can be brought to these systems to make
them even more appealing more better you
know like help the user create more
beautiful images so it would be just
amazing if we could just
adjust individual color hues and
saturations inside of the camera this
way we could match different camera
brands and create more complex profiles
for any kind of situations and that
would be just much more fun you know
like not everybody uh you know likes
color grading or you know not everybody
wants to be a colorist so
you know it would be just amazing to
create more interesting profiles so this
would be a game changer for sony color
so please sony if you watch this if
you're watching this just you know
consider doing this this would be
amazing for the user
um besides the color filter you can also
use the creative film lots to push
things even further
so let's jump into davinci to see how we
can do that the ones that are working in
davinci can buy the power grades which
actually give you full control over the
effects and can further enhance inside
the note panel
in davinci resolve install the luts by
making multiple powergrade folders
import the files into each folder
separately add new nodes by pressing alt
s on windows
and then just choose the one that you
like drag and drop onto each node a
different effect i usually go as first
node base slot second node film contrast
third node classic film color
and the last node is red halation
remember the power grades from da vinci
are fully customizable so you can
actually have full control over the
image and you can add your own
modifications
in this pack i prepared over 30
different contrast gammas and over 40
color schemes which results in more than
1 000 unique variations which is pretty
crazy right
also snuck in the exact same luts i have
used in the original video for each
profile plus one extra
so yeah have fun experimenting you
definitely have a lot to experiment with
like and share if you appreciate this
content subscribe if you want to see the
classic chrome film recipe coming up and
support the channel by buying the
creative luts or buy me a coffee till
next time have fun and see you later
you